welcome to the presentation on level
four division
so what makes level four division harder
than level three division is instead of
having a
one digit number being divided into a
multi-digit number we're not going to
have a two digit number divided into a
multi-digit number so let's get started
with some practice problems
so let's start with
what i would say is a relatively uh
straightforward example the level four
problems you'll see are actually a
little harder than this but let's say i
had
25
goes into
six thousand
two hundred
and fifty
so
the best way to think about this is you
say okay i have 25 does 25 go into 6
well no clearly 6 is smaller than 25 so
25 does not go into 6. so then ask
yourself well then if 25 doesn't go into
6 does 25 go into 62. well sure 62 is
larger than 25 so 25 will go into 62.
well let's think about it 25 times 1 is
25 25 times 2 is 50.
so that so it goes into 62 at least two
times and 25 times three is 75 so that's
too much so 25 goes into 62
two times
and there's really no mechanical way to
go about figuring this out you have to
kind of think about okay how many times
do i think 25 will go into 62. and
sometimes you get it wrong sometimes
you'll put a number here say i if i
didn't know i would have put a 3 up here
and then i would have said 3 times 25
and i got a 75 here and that would have
been too large of a number so i would
have gone back and changed it to a 2.
likewise if i had done a 1 and i did 1
times 25 when i subtracted when i
subtracted it out the difference i would
have gotten would be larger than 25 and
then i would know that okay 1 is too
small i have to increase it to 2.
i hope i didn't confuse you too much i
just want you to know that you shouldn't
get a nervous if you're like boy you
know every time i go through the step
it's kind of like
i kind of have to guess what the number
is as opposed to kind of a method and
that's true everyone has to do that so
anyway so 25 goes into 62 two times
now let's multiply 2 times 25 well 2
times 5
is 10
and then 2 times 2 plus 1
is 5 and we know that 25 times 2 is 50
anyway then we subtract 2 minus 0 is 2
6 minus 5 is 1.
and now we bring down the 5.
so the rest of the mechanics are pretty
much just like a level 3 division
problem
now we ask ourselves how many times does
25 go into 125
well the way i think about it is 25 it
goes into 100 about four times so it'll
go into 125 one more time it goes into
it five times if you weren't sure you
could try four and then you would see
that you would have too much left over
or if you tried six you would see that
um
that you would actually get six times 25
is a lot number larger than 125 so you
you don't you can't use six so if we say
25 goes into 125
5 times
then we just multiply 5 times 5 is 25
5 times 2
is 10 plus 2
125 so it goes in exact so 125 minus 125
is clearly zero
then we bring down this zero
and 25 goes into zero zero times
zero times 25 is zero remainder is zero
so we see that 25 goes into 600
6250
exactly
250 times let's do another problem
let's say i had
um let me pick an interesting number
let's say i had
15
and i want to know how many times
it goes into
2265.
well we just do the same thing we did
before we say okay does 15 go into 2 no
so does 15 go into 22 sure 15 goes into
22
one time notice we wrote the one above
the 22 if it had gone into two we would
have written the one here but 15 goes
into 22 one time
1 times 15
is 15
right 22 minus 15 we could do the whole
carrying thing 1 12
12
12 minus 5 is 7 1 minus 1 is 0. 22 minus
15 is 7.
bring down the 6.
okay now how many times does 15 go into
76. once again there isn't a real easy
mechanical way to do it you can kind of
eyeball it and estimate well 15 times 2
is 30 15 times 4 is 60.
15 times 5 is 75 that's pretty close so
let's say 15 goes into 76
five times
so 5 times five once again i already
figured out in my head but i'll just do
it again and five times one is five plus
seven
oh
sorry
five times five is twenty-five five
times 5
is 25 then 5 times 1 is 5 plus 2 is 7.
now we just subtract 6 minus 76 minus 75
is clearly 1.
bring down that 5.
well 15 goes into 15 exactly
one time
1 times 15 is 15.
subtract it we get a remainder of 0. so
15 goes into 2
265
exactly
151 times
so just think about what we're doing
here and and why it
it's a little bit harder than when you
have a one digit number here is that you
have to kind of think about well how
many times does this two-digit number go
into this larger number and since you
don't know uh
two-digit multiplication tables very few
people do you have to do a little bit of
guesswork sometimes you can look at this
first digit and look at the first digit
here and make an estimate but sometimes
it's trial and error you'll try it when
you multiply it out you might get it
wrong on the first try let's do another
problem
and actually i'm going to pick numbers
at random so it might not have an easy
remainder but i think you'll get the
point i won't teach you decimals now so
i'll just leave the remainder if there
is one
let's say i had
67
going into
500 or 5978
so i just picked these numbers randomly
out of my head so i'll show you that
i also sometimes have to do a little bit
of guesswork to figure out how many
times one of these two digit numbers go
into a larger number
so 67 goes into five zero times
67 goes into 59 zero times
67
goes into 597.
so what we have to kind of let's see 67
is almost 70
and 597 is almost 600
so
if it was
7
70 goes into
70 times 9 is 630 right because 7 times
9 is 63. so i'm gonna just eyeball
approximate i'm going to say that it
goes into it eight times i might be
wrong
and you can always check but we're going
to actually check in this step
essentially
8 times 7 well that's 56
and then 8 times 6
is 48
plus 2 is 53
53
seven minus six is one nine minus three
is six
five minus five is zero sixty-one so
good i got it right because if i got a
number here that was larger than
sixty-one that was
67 or larger then that means that this
number up here wasn't large enough but
here i got a number that's positive
because 536 is less than 597 and it's
less than 67 so i did that step right
so now we bring down this eight
now this one might be a little bit
trickier this time once again we have
almost 70 and here we have almost 630 so
maybe it will go into it nine times
well let's give it a try and see if it
does
nine times
nine times seven
is sixty-three
nine times six is fifty-four plus six is
sixty
good
so it did actually go into it 9 times
because 603 is less than 618
8 minus 3 is 5
1 minus 0 is 1 and 6 minus 6
is 0.
so we have
now that we have a remainder of 15 which
is smaller than 67 so i'm not going to
teach you decimals right now so we can
just leave that remainder so we could
say is that 67 goes into 5978
89 times
and when it goes into it 89 times you're
left with a remainder of 15.
hopefully that you're ready now to try
some level 4 division problems
have fun